carrusel de las artes
a maría carolina piña
[Música]
un gusto saludarles desde estrasburgo
hoy vamos a llorar en nuestro programa
esta otra ciudad de luz considerada
capital de la navidad y conocida por su
tradicional mercado
[Música]
en este número de carrusel de las artes
visitaremos la capital de aisa hacia
estrasburgo una ciudad de historia y
barrios pintorescos su casco histórico
ha sido inscrito en la lista del
patrimonio mundial de la unesco
estrasburgo es conocida por su mercado
navideño tradición que remonta al siglo
16 y que lo hace uno de los más antiguos
en europa desde la plaza clave a la
catedral y las callejuelas del casco
histórico toda la ciudad de estrasburgo
vibra al ritmo de la navidad con
iluminaciones suntuosas y les hablaremos
del arbolito gigante emblema de la
ciudad durante la navidad la leyenda
cuenta que la tradición del arbolito
navideño se originó aquí en alsacia
[Música]
estrasburgo la capital de la región de
alsacia es un concentrado de patrimonio
arquitectónico e histórico estamos muy
cerca de la frontera con alemania algo
que puede verse en las fachadas de las
casas típicas con sus entramados de
madera
y para hablarnos más en detalle sobre la
ciudad tenemos cita con alguien que
conoce a estrasburgo como la palma de su
mano iván de la torre muchísimas gracias
por recibirnos aquí en estrasburgo
bienvenida maría colorín a estrasburgo
capital de alsacia y es un placer
recibirte a la ciudad iván y bueno tú
eres franco-española habitante de la
ciudad y guía turístico tiene
estrasburgo cuéntanos cuáles son los
lugares emblemáticos que debemos ver o
si o si aquí en la ciudad bueno pues
traigo una ciudad bastante grande pesado
que la gente cree pero podríamos decir
tres grandes barrios el centro histórico
en los que destacamos la catedral y el
barrio de la pequeña francia también
tenemos el barrio alemán o barrio de la
no vista que ha sido declarado
patrimonio de la humanidad recientemente
2017 y por último tenemos la zona de las
instituciones europeas con el parlamento
de la unión europea y el consejo de
europa y ahora ese barrio que se llama
el apetito con la pequeña francia que
podemos encontrar allí bueno pues es un
barrio encantador es el más pintoresco
de la ciudad donde encontramos un gran
conjunto de casas de entramados de
madera en su mayor parte del siglo 16 en
adelante y tiene un nombre muy peculiar
porque muchos visitantes creen que es un
nombre en honor a francia debido a la
libre entre la segunda guerra mundial y
en cambio su nombre derivado de una
enfermedad la sífilis ya que era el
lugar donde se concentraban las personas
y políticas que tenían el mar francés y
ahora está este casco histórico de
estrasburgo pero no los comentabas se
llama lago con chile la gran isla y
justamente es uno de los lugares que ha
sido inscrito en la lista del patrimonio
mundial de la unesco exactamente el lago
1000 como son ahora indicas una isla es
una elipse insular rodeada por el río y
al sur y un brazo de este al norte es un
afluente del río río que nos separa de
alemania y ha sido inscrito con este
nombre a la lista de la unesco junto con
el otro barrio del cual te hablaba la no
vista que también se ha escrito con su
nombre en alemán a pesar de que ahora
estamos en francia
iván estamos aquí en estrasburgo en el
período navideño para ver ese mercado de
navidad que es una tradición que remonta
a varios siglos y me parece que los
extras burgueses los llamamos incluso
con la denominación de la lengua
alsaciana exactamente aunque el dialecto
se está perdiendo todavía se sigue
llamando el kitsch méxico es un poco
complejo de pronunciar es el mercado del
niño jesús' traducido al castellano y es
un mercado que existe desde 1570
originalmente era un mercado muy pequeño
ubicada en la catedral que ha ido
cambiando de lugar y hoy tenemos hasta
14 mercados diferentes en toda la ciudad
de estrasburgo principalmente en su
centro histórico bueno yo no lo voy a
poder pronunciar como tú no los acabas
de hacer en lenguas anciana pero vamos a
ir justamente en carrusel de las artes a
visitar ese mercado de navidad
muchísimas gracias iván por todas estas
explicaciones sí y buena visita
[Música]
el mercado de navidad de estrasburgo es
en realidad un conjunto de pequeños
mercados distribuidos en el casco
histórico de la ciudad uno de los
lugares es la catedral notre damme y por
esta zona conocimos a guillaume lipsic a
uno de los responsables de la ciudad
quien nos habló de la edición 2021
[Música]
y
el mercado de estrasburgo es el más
antiguo y el más importante de toda
francia este año llegamos a la edición
número 451 de este mercado de navidad en
2021 el mercado está desplegado en 12
lugares distintos con
314 chalets opuestos repartidos en todo
el casco histórico de la ciudad con lo
que queremos invitar a los habitantes ya
los turistas a entrar en el universo
navideño y a visitar el centro de
estrasburgo
todos los años recibimos unos 2 millones
de visitantes durante el mercado lo que
constituye un desafío logístico
considerable en un contexto de crisis
sanitaria la gran mayoría de los
contagios tiene lugar en espacios
cerrados sin embargo diseñamos un plan
de circulación con mayor espacio entre
los puestos y con chalets más amplios
para frenar la transmisión del virus
dentro del mercado hay que recordar
además que en 2018 sufrimos un atentado
terrorista
aquí en estrasburgo eso nos llevó a
concebir un plan de seguridad compatible
con los tiempos que vivimos
[Música]
gypsy que diría usted que aquí se
celebra una verdadera navidad al
alsaciano
[Música]
en estas tierras solemos decir que hay
una verdadera navidad a la alsaciana y
me atrevería a decir que las navidades
en otras zonas del mundo están
inspiradas como la de alsacia eso se
siente en nuestro mercado de estrasburgo
la gente tiene ganas de pasarla bien de
vivir la navidad en familia es la época
más importante del año para los
alsacianos
gracias guillaume lipsic y nosotros
vamos ahora a la plaza que le vert la
más grande de estrasburgo allí cada año
con motivo del mercado de navidad se
instala un pino gigante que se ha
convertido en una de las atracciones más
admiradas por esta época es lo que nos
contó su director artístico guión
pepillo
[Música]
y
el arbolito gigante es la gran atracción
de la navidad en estrasburgo para los
habitantes de la ciudad es como un
símbolo porque es uno de los más grandes
de europa mide casi 30 metros de alto
pero además porque es una tradición
íntimamente ligada a nuestra historia
hoy sabemos gracias a documentos
antiguos que hace por lo menos 500 años
la gente de estas tierras usó a pinos
para celebrar la navidad así que el
arbolito es un emblema de las fiestas
navideñas en alsacia y forma parte de
nuestro patrimonio
[Música]
y
este año hemos querido adornar este
arbolito gigante con lunas y estrellas
cada navidad escogemos un tema y este
año la invitación es a alumbrar las
estrellas el arbolito nos conecta con el
cielo con la imaginación es algo que nos
transporta hacia las alturas o hacia lo
divino en 2021 utilizamos materiales
sencillos naturales como la madera con
la que fabricamos esas estrellas y lunas
hay esferas rojas que nos recuerdan las
manzanas con las que se adornaban los
arbolitos en el pasado y azules que
evocan las nubes también nos inspiramos
en la catedral otro emblema de
estrasburgo que busca conectar con el
cielo en definitiva este arbolito es un
concentrado de la cultura alsaciana y
estrasburguesa erigido en el medio de
esta gran plaza kléber
[Música]
en 2021 el eslogan es alumbrar las
estrellas para nosotros es una forma de
entrar en este periodo mágico que es la
navidad con sus leyendas y cuentos para
los católicos es la época de las viento
y ese es el objetivo del mercado de
estrasburgo preparar en familia entre
amigos la fiesta de la navidad es una
época de generosidad en la que pensamos
en los demás hacemos regalos cada quien
lo vive a su manera y por eso hay muchas
cosas para hacer y disfrutar en
estrasburgo en la alcaldía hay cuentos
para niños hay un mercado solidario cada
plaza tiene su mercado hay espectáculos
hay una programación vasta y variada
para todos los gustos
[Música]
y en la plaza kléber frente al arbolito
gigante de navidad vamos a conversar con
otro habitante y conocedor de las
tradiciones de esta ciudad vladimiro
bordones hola vladímir hola maría
carolina vladimir ya explícanos esta
tradición del arbolito de navidad que
finalmente se usa en todo el mundo creo
saber que nació aquí en alsacia
exactamente la tradición del árbol de
navidad solemos decir de que nace acá en
la región de alsacia debido a que el
primer documento en el cual se menciona
la existencia de un árbol de navidad es
en 1521 en la ciudad de celeste que no
está muy lejos de estrasburgo las
decoraciones son bastante simples
originalmente colocamos en alsacia
manzanas que nos recuerdan la tentación
de eva y adán por la serpiente y
utilizamos igualmente las hostias
aquellas que utilizamos en la iglesia
símbolo de la redención
posteriormente vamos a utilizar por
ejemplo
incluso comida vamos a utilizar bread el
pan de especias para decorar los árboles
de navidad y se suele decir que a fines
del siglo 19 en alsacia hay un proceso
de sequía pero nos permite tener los
medios para decorar un árbol de navidad
y es así como surgen eventualmente las
bolas de navidad a canals hacia las más
populares son por ejemplo aquellas de
maíz en tal a que vienen de los vosgos y
son muy famosas actualmente en el
mercado una vida
[Música]
el primer mercado de navidad se da en la
ciudad de estrasburgo en 1570 en este
periodo estrasburgo pertenece al sacro
imperio romano germánico el primer raid
y los mercados de navidad son
tradicionales de estos lugares del
premier rise por lo tanto en el mercado
de navidad surge acá en europa central
pero posteriormente esta tradición va a
llegar a otros lugares del mundo
vladimir y cuéntanos cuánto tiempo dura
el arbolito de navidad y el mercado de
navidad aquí en estrasburgo el árbol de
navidad lo vamos a poder disfrutar un
mes las celebraciones comenzaron el 26
de noviembre este mes de preparación
espiritual que nos recuerda la llegada
de jesucristo
originalmente se celebraba el 6 de
diciembre este tipo de fiestas san
nicolás santo de turquía que entrega
regalos a los niños
el movimiento protestante va a tener
problemas con esta situación no podemos
permitir que un santo un humano entregue
regalos es así como esto pasa a ser un
regalo del crist kindle
cristo y por eso actualmente se llaman
alsacia christine del madrid gracias
vladimir bordones por todas esas
explicaciones sobre el arbolito de
navidad de estrasburgo muchas gracias
[Música]
y
y es debajo de los ángeles luminosos de
la calle que lleva a la catedral que
ponemos punto final a este carrusel de
las artes especiales que les presentamos
desde la ciudad de estrasburgo capital
de la navidad muchísimas gracias por su
sintonía y hasta la próxima agua
[Música]